hallo ihr lieben heute mal ein etwas
anderer blog von mir und zwar bin ich
heute auf der wolfgang borchert
gesamtschule in recklinghausen was ich
da machte fragte
hauswirtschaftsunterricht das habe ich
noch nie gemacht ich habe zu meiner
nichte gebacken meiner kleinen schwester
mit ein bis zwei kindern wer auch nicht
und heute werden die ganze 17 kinder
seien also nicht auch was ganz neues
aber ich wurde eingeladen dort
hauswirtschaftsunterricht zu machen und
das mache ich es super gerne und ich
habe vor mit denen kindern die übrigens
weiter von 716 jahrzehnten stocker mit
dem nur die tore zu machen und als
bisher leckeren pfannkuchen proteine
sich einfach austoben können und jetzt
nochmal zum hintergrund der klasse
das sind kinder die jetzt spät deutsch
gelernt haben das ist eine
vorbereitungsklasse daher sind wir auch
kinder im alter von zehn bis 16 jahren
was ja auch eigentlich eine normale
klasse sehr untypisch ist aber dort in
dem schüler die spät deutsch gelernt
haben auf grund
dessen weil eventuell sie und die eltern
geflüchtet sind oder weil die eltern
hier in deutschland einen job gefunden
haben
also da ist alles dabei ich weiß selber
nicht welche schülerinnen und schüler
mich da erfahre ich bin sehr gespannt
und ich freue mich schon richtig drauf
und wir sehen uns dann gleich in der
klasse wieder und das ist ein sommer
gucken wir brauchen keinen küchenwaage
wir messen auch mitgeteilt werden
derzeit steht auf ein für den 3
dann macht ihr am 23
[Musik]
wir wollen dass der kuchen noch schmeckt
steht dann ist das richtig machen
funktioniert auch etwas dem open drin
sind genau richtig
[Musik]
das machst du schalker profi vom aktiven
profis alles mit liebe gemacht deswegen
[Musik]
und wieso
[Gelächter]
denn nach und hält und wenn dann nicht
mehr
du bist ein mann ein mann doch nicht
weil ja aber du hast alle nicht drin
[Musik]
ich soll nicht essen ich soll auch nicht
essen
[Musik]
ja
was habt ihr gemacht
eine seite mit gc die andere seite auch
ihr vorgemacht wie kalle zuckerschock
noch
[Musik]
haben wir doch gut hinbekommen immerhin
ist doch machbar oder
[Musik]
haben wir alle drauf wann sollte
fleißigsten wir unseren kuchen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so ihr lieben das war's von meinem
schultag mit den kids das hat mir
unglaublich viel spaß gemacht und die
haben auch samstags gearbeitet also
nochmal ein großes lob an alle wenn dir
das hier sind denn ich bin sicher ihr
werdet euch das video anschauen und wir
sind jetzt in der neuen wohnung wir
arbeiten dem ziel fleißig weiter ich
werde ich auf jeden fall die rezepte in
die infobox verlinken bzw meinen nudeln
mit thunfisch so sein rezept das gibt's
ja schon auf youtube das verlegen ich
euch und das andere das schreibe ich
euch schriftlich auf den vielleicht habt
ihr auch los mit kindern was zu button
und dann ist es eben perfekt denn ihr
braucht keine maschine
es ist total leicht zu überstehen würde
euch alles so aufschreiben wie ich das
auch den kids gegeben habe und dann
wünsche ich euch ganz viel spaß nach
backen und nachkochen und ich hoffe dass
euch diese andere art von bock gefallen
hat und dann sehen wir uns in meinem die
lernvideos